zuma simplifica la respuesta y escríbela
como número mixto aquí tenemos dos
números mixtos tienen una parte entera y
la otra parte es una fracción una manera
de sumar estos dos números mixtos es
pasarlos a fracciones impropias sumar
las fracciones y luego el resultado
pasarlo de nuevo número mixto que rollo
no pero también puedes decir a ver a ver
17 enteros dos novenos es lo mismo que
17 enteros
más dos novenos
por otra parte cinco enteros un noveno
es lo mismo que cinco enteros más un
noveno y los queremos sumar estas dos
proposiciones son totalmente
equivalentes ahora tenemos un montón de
números que estamos sumando y sabemos
que cuando sumamos el orden no nos
importa entonces esto lo podemos
escribir como 17 más
más dos novenos
más
1 -
básicamente lo que hice fue primero
poner los números enteros y luego poner
las fracciones
esta parte de aquí es 17 -cinco que
sabemos que es 22
esta parte de aquí
son dos fracciones que tenemos que sumar
dos novenos más un noveno como tienen el
mismo denominador la fracción será entre
9 y ahora solamente nos queda sumar los
numeradores dos más uno que es 3
y obtenemos tres novenos pero observa
que esto lo podemos simplificar porque
tanto el numerador como el denominador
los podemos dividir entre 3 entonces 3
entre 3
la 1 y 9 entre 3
y ya terminamos la suma
porque 22 más un tercio es lo mismo que
un tercio